le mois prochain la NASA va lancer un
satellite dernier cri dédié à l'étude de
l'eau la mission soit va observer avec
une précision inégalée les mouvements de
l'eau sur terre et les impacts des
changements climatiques sur cette
précieuse ressource
de l'espace le bleu est saisissant
[Musique]
on scrute le mouvement des eaux depuis
des décennies mais avec l'arrivée du
satellite de la mission soit tout va
changer on s'attend la Révolution la
révolution soit les données ça va être
faux
nous allons voir l'eau comme Jeannot
auparavant ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
soit ça va nous permettre de savoir où
est l'eau et où elle va
l'eau elle monte puis redescend
parfois elle se déchaîne
souvent elle se fait rare
la ressource est constamment en
mouvement une dynamique qui fascine
Cédric David hydrologue à la NASA en
Californie
c'est la même mot que les dinosaures ont
bu c'est cool ça c'est un peu fascinant
mais voilà donc bien sûr ça bouge dans
le cycle combien on a d'eau combien on
est combien on a besoin
comment ça change
et comment on fait pour
pour éviter la catastrophe
[Musique]
j'aime bien penser au débit dans les
rivières du monde comme comme les
artères de la terre qu'avec l'eau qui
s'écoule et de la même manière que on va
chez le docteur et qu'on mesure qu'on
mesure on mesure notre tour on va
pouvoir faire ça pour la planète
[Musique]
son intérêt pour prendre le pouls de la
planète va bien au-delà de la science je
suis né avec un handicap physique qui
qui a affecté mes deux jambes et donc
marcher ça a jamais été fun mais par
contre nager ouais donc quand je suis
dans l'eau je suis pareil je suis pareil
que tout le monde
tirez le meilleur d'une épreuve c'est
avec cette attitude qui la rejoint la
NASA
aujourd'hui Cédric David de dirige une
mission et pas n'importe laquelle la
mission soit
c'est une mission qui est qui va nous
aider à comprendre la circulation des
océans et l'évolution du cycle de l'eau
de surface sur terre donc rivière lac et
réservoir
l'eau elle peut être ici maintenant elle
peut être là-bas dans 6 mois on peut
avoir trop d'eau ici maintenant et pas
assez d'eau ici dans 6 mois
soit c'est un peu comme un photographe
en orbite avec ses lentilles nouveaux
genres il pourra cartographier les eaux
de la planète
90% des lacs et des rivières et les
océans aussi les cartes produites seront
10 fois plus précises c'est un peu comme
si on avait un seul œil et puis d'un
coup on en a deux
ok c'est ce type de révolution
l'autre première c'est que les
hydrologues auront enfin leur satellite
leur propre instruments des outils
adaptés pour étudier les rivières et les
lacs cette mission utilise une
technologie qui est complètement
complètement nouvelle on n'a jamais
utilisé donc ça va être une grande
première
cette nouvelle carte graphie est devenue
possible grâce à un bijou technologique
le radar interféromètre le radar envoie
un signal vers la terre dès que le
signal frappe-le il rebondit vers le
satellite une fois capté il est
retransmis sur Terre on analyse ensuite
le signal
voilà la hauteur des ours se dévoilent
avec une précision de 10 cm on va
pouvoir mesurer la hauteur des océans à
peu près à cette avec cette précision là
ok donc ça c'est dingue ça c'est dingue
avant soit les satellites voyaient la
présence des eaux rien de plus mais avec
soi on obtient une vision dynamique des
eaux
et quand on mélange les cartes avec la
hauteur ça nous permet de de déterminer
plein de trucs par exemple les
changements de stock les changements de
volume d'eau partout autour de la
planète et ainsi que le débit
ce qui est incroyable c'est que les
données seront actualisées un portrait
complet de la ressource sera disponible
tous les 21 jours et pour un pays comme
le Canada c'est une mine d'or de
renseignements à l'heure actuelle on
connaît très peu le débit et le niveau
des lacs et des rivières seulement 5%
d'entre eux sont monitory en haute
latitude comme le Canada et la Russie il
y a des il y a des eaux surfaces partout
et elles sont interconnectées partout et
donc on sait qu'ils disons mais on sait
pas trop bien où sont les frontières et
on sait pas dans quelle direction
l'eau va aller soit très prendra cette
question de l'information essentielle
pour suivre un l'évolution du territoire
et pour améliorer la gestion de la
ressource
Cédric David attend les premiers
résultats avec impatience et il n'est
pas le seul d'autres chercheurs
trépignent aussi
ils attendent des données toutes
fraîches pour améliorer leur modèle de
prédiction avec plusieurs années on va
pouvoir modifier tous ces modèles
numériques pour qu'ils pour qu'ils ne
marche mieux avec des vraies données
qu'on a jamais eu jusqu'à présent
estimer les pertes d'eau
prédire la force d'un ouragan et évaluer
le risque d'inondation et de sécheresse
si on a la chance de faire la mesure au
bon moment d'une crue par exemple d'une
cru d'inondation si on est assez malin
qu'on télécharge la donnée assez
rapidement on l'analyse rapidement et
qu'on passe un coup de fil à ceux qui
sont en aval pour leur dire là je vous
préviens d'ici deux jours ça va ça va
tomber ça va péter les os vont monter
même si l'objectif de la mission est
clair reste qu'une part de mystère
entoure le projet on sait jamais ce
qu'on va trouver c'est ça qui est un peu
fou c'est tous des rôles comme prévu
Cédric David verra son satellite
décoller au mois de décembre c'est 20
ans de rêves de rêve scientifiques de
rêve d'ingénierie aussi de gens qui
travaillent ensemble qui luttent c'est
des galères jusqu'au moment où pas mais
ça monte
la population augmente mais la quantité
d'eau elle reste la même ici la quête de
Cédric David prend tout son sens savoir
où se trouve l'eau et où elle va
[Musique]